we're here at the Consumer Electronics
Show in Las Vegas and just witnessed a
somewhat unusual event at a booth
showing a hoverboard like product
federal marshals showed up and seized
all of the merchandise within the booth
took down all the signs and carted it
away the manufacturer a Chinese company
was accused of infringing on the patent
of one wheel a startup that introduced a
very similar product a couple years ago
at the show
one wheel says this company essentially
just made its product and started
selling it for cheaper and having it
here the show damages its reputation we
have patents both in the US and
internationally on on both the design
and the function of one wheel and so we
engaged our IP lawyers because we heard
that they were going to be knockoffs of
the one wheel product appearing at CES
so we went through the formal US legal
process to get a temporary restraining
order against one of these companies
that's trying to sell a knockoff product
in the States the first time there's
been a lot of concern about low-quality
hoverboards Catching Fire hurting people
and this company felt that if there was
another one on the market that looked
exactly like it it could end up hurting
its own sales as well knockoffs often
don't have the same level of engineering
effort put into them many times the
companies can make them don't even
really understand what they're building
and so that's very damaging to the
market as a whole
[Music]